you know there's a llama you you can
open source once it's trained you can
open source a model yeah and for fine
tuning and all that kind of stuff like
what do you is the pros and cons of that
of open sourcing based
models um I think the cmer to open
sourcing I think perhaps with a slight
time delay you know I don't know six six
months even
um I think I'm I'm generally in favor of
open sourcing like bias towards open
sourcing
um I mean it it is a concern to me that
you know open you know I was you know I
think I guess arguably the
prime you know Prime move behind open AI
in the sense that it was created because
of discussions that I had with Larry
pagee um back when he and I were were
friends and St his house and and I
talked to him about AI safety and and
Larry did not care about AI safety or at
least at the time he didn't um you know
and at one point he called me a speciest
for being pro-human and I'm like well
what team are you on
Larry uh still on team robot to be and
I'm like okay so at the time you know uh
Google Google had had acquired deep mind
they had uh probably 2/3 of all AI res
you know probably two3 of all the AI
researchers in the world mhm that
basically infinite money and
compute and the guy in
charge you know Larry paage did not care
about safety and even yelled at me um
and and called me a
specious Pro human so I don't know if
you know about humans they can change
their mind and maybe you and Larry Paige
can still can be friends once more I'd
like to be friends with Larry again um
he he's he he got really the the the the
the breaking of the friendship was over
openingi um and
specifically um I think the the key
moment was recruiting Ilia s Sky um so I
love Ilia he's so brilliant il's good
good human uh smart good heart
um and um that was that was a tough
recruiting
battle um it was mostly Demis on one
side and me on the other both trying to
IIA and Ilia went back and forth you
know going to stay at Google he was
going to leave then he was going to stay
then he leave and and finally he he did
agree to join
openi that was one of the toughest
recruiting battles we' ever had and but
that that was really the the Lynch pin
for openi being successful and I was you
know also instrumental in recruiting a
number of other people and I provided
all the funding in the
beginning um over $40
million um and the
name the the opening opening ey is
supposed to mean open source and it was
created as a nonprofit open source and
now it is a closed source for maximum
profit which I think is not good
comma but like we talked about with war
and leaders talking I do hope that
there's only a few folks working on this
at the highest level I do hope you
reinvigorate friendships here like I
said I'd like to be friends again with
Larry I haven't seen him in ages um and
we were friends for a very long time I
met I met Larry P before he got funding
for Google or actually I guess before he
got Venture funding I think it he got
the first like 100k from I think back to
or someone um it's wild to think about
all that happened and you've guys known
each other that whole time just 20 years
since maybe 98 or something yeah it's
crazy crazy how much has happened since
then yeah 25 years
a lot of happens insane but you're
seeing the tension there like maybe
delayed open source Del I yeah like what
is the source that is open you know what
I mean like there's basically it's a
giant CSV
file yeah yeah with a bunch of numbers
yep um what do you do with that giant
file of numbers you know how do you
run like the amount of actual the lines
of code is very small mhm
um and and most of the work um the
software work is in the in the curation
of the data so it's like trying to
figure out what data is separating good
data from Bad data like um like you
can't just crawl the internet because
there's a lot of junk out there um a
huge percentage of websites have more
noise than signal you know they're
they're because they're just us for
search engine optimization they're
literally just scan
websites